we begin this morning with what could be
a huge diplomatic breakthrough with
North Korea the rogue nation says it has
suspended its nuclear and long-range
missile tests and will close its nuclear
test site but there was no mention of
North Korea giving up its nuclear
program the surprise announcement comes
just days before North Korean leader Kim
jong-un is expected to meet for a summit
with South Korean president moon jae-in
president Trump welcomed the news and
said he is looking forward to his
upcoming historic summit with Kim the
president is that his mar-a-lago resort
in Florida Errol Barnett is with the
president and joins us with the latest
Darrel good morning good morning
a major breakthrough with North Korea
would be a much-needed welcome
development for president Trump who
while he's been spending the week down
here in South Florida has been mired in
mounting legal issues from the criminal
case against his personal attorney to a
new civil lawsuit filed by the DNC
against his campaign but soon after this
news out of North Korea President Trump
was fast to describe it as progress
being made for all four decades North
Korean missile tests have been
expressions of tactical strength but now
leader Kim Jong hoon is showing a
willingness to end them North Korea's
state media reported Kim saying that as
of today North Korea will suspend
long-range missile tests and close a
nuclear test site president Trump
responded late Friday saying quote this
is very good news for North Korea and
the world look forward to our summit the
president is preparing for a one-on-one
meeting with Kim sometime in the next
two months on north and south korea is
set to hold talks next week we've never
been in a position like this with that
regime whether its father grandfather or
son on Wednesday during a joint press
conference with Japanese Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe a the president downplayed
what could be accomplished when he meets
with Kim if I think that it's a meeting
that is not going to be fruitful we're
not going to go if the meeting when I'm
there is not fruitful I will
respectfully
leave the meeting it is in stark
contrast to mr. Trump's language last
summer following one of North Korea's
many threats and missile tests they will
be met with fire fury and frankly power
the likes of which this world has never
seen before
president Trump also faces a May 12th
deadline to renew or reject u.s.
participation in the Iran nuclear deal
in an interview with Face the Nation
moderator Margaret Brennan iran's
Foreign Minister said if the u.s. pulls
out of the agreement his country is
prepared to restart its nuclear program
we have put a number of options for
ourselves and those options are ready
including options that would involve
resuming at a much greater speed our
nuclear activities
now President Trump heads back to
Washington
Sunday and will host French president
Emmanuel macron for the first state
visit of his administration on Monday a
senior White House official says the two
will discuss Iran's nuclear activities
as well as concerns President Trump has
over Iran's activities in the region
Dana
Errol Barnett with the president in
Florida Thank You Errol